[موسيقى]
تحركاته اثار جدلا بين السودانيين خلال
الساعه الماضيه فمنهم من يرى انها مجرد
خطوه يسعى من خلالها قائد الدعم السريع
لرمي كره الهدنه بملعب البرهان وجاء هذا
في وقت نددت فيه العديد من المنظمات
الحقوقيه الدوليه والمحليه بالانتهاكات
المتواصله التي تتعرض لها النساء في
السودان حيث كشف تقرير نشرته الامم
المتحده مؤخرا عن تعرض النساء في السودان
لانتهاكات مروعه تشمل الاغتصاب والاستغلال
الجنسيه والعنف الجسديه كما كشف مكتب مفوض
الامم المتحده السامي لحقوق الانسان فولكر
ترك قبل ايام عن تلقيه تقارير عن اعمال
عنف جنسي ضد ما لا يقل عن 53 امراه موضحا
ان قرابه 20 امراه تم اغتصابه في هجوم
واحد من جهه اخرى اتهمت اللجنه التمهيديه
لنقابه اطباء السودان قوات الدعم السريع
بارتكاب جرائم اغتصاب في الحرب الدائره
مطالبه بضغط دولي لايقاف هذه الجرائم
المتوحشه وغير الانسانيه على حد وصفها
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات